[Music]
kazaya is with us in minneapolis hi
kaziah how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm getting married in february
and um i am living in an apartment right
now with a couple of friends but i'm
looking for an apartment to move into
before i get married so then i won't be
as hectic during the wedding
and there's just not a lot of apartments
available in my area
and i don't have a credit score
which is totally fine
but um i also me and my fiance both just
got new jobs recently so we also don't
have any like proof of income to show
the apartment
so we don't exactly know how to go about
that
when did you get the jobs
um like three weeks ago
and they're looking for like multiple
months and i had jobs before
of course but they're looking for
someone that i'm like currently employed
with
i think you've talked to two apartments
we did an interesting thing we did an
experimenter here a while back
we called all the major apartment
complexes in the nashville area like 30
of them
two of them required a credit score
oh yeah i i i'm totally i called them
and they're totally fine with me not
having a credit score i agree with that
um but they just need a proof of income
which i have an income i know so just
get a letter from your employer i'm
gainfully employed i just started a new
job i'm getting married i mean how many
pay stubs do they need yeah she said
like they want multiple years or
something for a freaking apartment
that's silly no
you
i mean you're not a freelancer right
this is a salaried position
um i have a like a lot of my income is
from babysitting and then from an
internship and then from a preschool so
i have multiple streams of income but my
main one right so you don't have a pay
stub except from the preschool
yeah except for the preschool yeah
so that that's your problem yeah yeah i
think you need to look around and find a
landlord find an apartment who's willing
to look at all the sources of income and
say hey this is clearly something that
you can afford and uh recently on the
fine print we did this day and we called
all around the country we called normal
single-family homes with landlords we
called apartment complexes and all of
them just said hey you might need a
little more deposit so you're just going
to need to explain your situation like a
human and they should be willing to work
with you if you find the right place
yeah occasionally you'll run into
somebody who's just being a corporate
geek and is following the barney fife
letter of the law or something but but
most of the time you can say okay look
here i can show you the budget i can
show you exactly what's going on i'll
show you i've got these six jobs
babysitting and there i'm a legitimate
nanny this is what i do it's just
independent subcontract and i've got
this this stuff pay stub and your fiance
if uh if he's signing on it as well if
he has a traditional pay stub that'll be
enough as well
but um yeah you're gonna run into uh
some people that aren't gonna understand
without a cr without a credit score and
you're going to run into some people
that don't understand without uh a
traditional job
but um but you just have to search a
little bit more that's why i was
challenging the number of times you've
done this and the other thing is this
quit emailing people and texting them
go sit down and look at them in the face
and that'll change the that'll change
your outcome as well
go sit down like you seem like a very
reasonable person i'm sure you present
well sitting in front of someone and say
here's the story here's the situation
i'm getting married here's the guy i'm
getting married to and would you all
consider it in this situation no
no
no
yes
you know that's what you're gonna get
you're gonna get a few no's and you're
gonna get a yes and you you can find
someone to do this but it is going to
take more than just everybody does your
deal because everybody doesn't do any
deal yeah and if you go there and you
get a tour and you sit down face to face
i think it is a different situation than
a cold email
definitely but you guys just jumped on
the phone now you were doing a credit
score only you weren't trying to we
asked about the whole situation they
said well you need to we need to have
proof of income
and we need to make sure you're not a
criminal that was it and other than that
they said you might need a higher
deposit which you'll get back if you
don't trash the place and that was it
and with with her income being multiple
streams and some of them being
self-employed like babysitting and so
forth she may have to put down a higher
deposit yeah in that situation because
the proof of income is what she's
running into but still um
you know
i i've got a bunch of rental property
and we would rent to you but you're
gonna have to make the case
it's not gonna be just automatic like
you know well i'll make some money
babysitting that's not no no you gotta
show me what's going on i gotta know you
can pay the freaking rent and then our
you're not talking to me anyway but our
property management team that's what
they would do